This 2.024 will be a decisive year in global politics with
elections in 76 countries Almost half of the world's population
will elect new rulers Let's see some of the most relevant elections.
June 02 is the elections in Mexico The presidency will be renewed on
Tuesday and thousands of positions throughout the country For the
presidency will be Claudia Sheinbaum for Morena and allies Xóchitl
Gálvez for the broad front and whoever the citizens'
movement chooses as representative.
But there is much more at stake In 9 entities including Mexico City,
legislators will be elected In addition,
the Federal Treasury will be renewed,
both the Chamber of Deputies and the Senate and most
of the local congresses With the exception of Coahuila.
November 5,
the United States prepares for its presidential election.
A new showdown between current Democratic President Joe
Biden and his Republican predecessor Donald Trump is anticipated.
After an election in 2020 marked by controversy and misinformation
the political climate in the United States is more polarized than
ever The central themes of the campaign are sure to include economics,
foreign policy,
especially migration,
civil rights,
international security and global economic relations.
El Salvador begins the Latin American electoral cycle.
February 04 There,
Buquelele seeks reelection in a context of constitutional
controversy that in theory prohibited consecutive terms.
Despite this,
he is quite popular thanks to a strong security strategy that has
reduced homicides andted areas that were previously controlled by gangs.
Presidential elections will be held in Venezuela following intense
negotiations where agreements were reached to hold them in exchange for the
lifting of international sanctions Obviously Nicolás Maduro after more than a
decade in power prepares to seek reelection The opposition led by María Corina
Machado faces a monumental challenge due to his disqualification from holding
public office and the great doubt about the fairness and
transparency of the electoral process.
March 17 Russia prepares for a crucial presidential election
Vladimir Putin a dominant figure in Russian politics since year 2.
000 seeks another mandate thanks to a
controversial constitutional reform approved in 2.
020 The political landscape in Russia has witnessed growing
hostility against the opposition and civil society especially in the
of the conflict in Ukraine These elections will not only determine
Russia's future but will also have a significant impact on global geos This 2.
024 elections around the world will not
only define the future of their nations,
but will also define international coexistence in the coming years.